thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am Ramsay
personality Rachel Cruz hosting today
with my good friend and fellow Ramsay
personality Dr John deloney and we are
here again to answer questions about
life and money so give us a call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right up first we have John in
Nashville hey John welcome to the show
hey y'all thanks for taking my call
absolutely John how can we help
so
my wife and I have a good bit of money
in savings and
we're uh not sure whether we go debt
free route or if we work towards
homeownership but use that money to put
down on a house
okay yeah it's a good question how much
you guys have saved
we have uh right at seventy thousand
okay and that's non-retirement savings
just in the bank no we're 25 it's it's
all in um sitting in savings okay
perfect and how much debt do you guys
have
I'm gonna say right at 100 to 110. okay
what's the what's the debt consist of
um it's a truck that still lacks about
30 or 35 there's a boat
um it's SLO 49 on it and then
we have 30 I have 30 in student loan
okay how much you guys make a year
five households like 140. 135 okay
um yeah I mean
my my first response is yeah you don't
need to be buying a house right now
because you guys have a lot of debt you
have a lot of stuff
uh hanging around your neck when it
comes to payments and everything and so
um no I would take that 70 grand and
start
paying off this debt I mean how how how
like financially
in pain it's kind of a weird question
but like do you guys feel this urgency
of like oh wow we have a we have a lot
of debt like we have almost as much debt
as we do you know making an income a
year do you all have a sense of urgency
or are you all kind of just living life
and you're cool well no not at all to be
honest um
I know that he's the wrong answer on
this show but um so the boat
I I when I go to sell it I'll Stand to
make 12 to 15 000 on it given the market
right now you know the Market's not
great with interest rates um the boat I
mean I've been paying
over the minimum payment since we got it
so I I still think even if I sold it you
know it should rank another five or so
to the to our pockets
um and I have a company truck so I'm in
the truck it just sits in the garage
um
I just I I don't feel the urge to really
and we don't know that's that's why I'm
calling not sure what the best idea to
do is because I feel like I could get
rid of all that by the end of next week
if I yeah if I really wanted to yeah
seven yeah for sure so why why don't you
want to
well a large amount of money from our
savings came from
um
a fishing tournament of course so I
fished kind of a semi-professional level
and
at the end of the day we still we still
only live on
35 to 65 percent of our income
um
let me say let me say it this way um my
father-in-law's on the circuit too so I
totally get that world I get that life
and I get showing up with this boat with
those trucks I get all that
um
on the flip side
my wife and I
um Dave is very generous to my family
and when we bought a house
um I was driving a 2012 truck with right
under 200 000 miles on it
Dave would give me a hard time about it
but what was more important to me was to
give my wife a home and give our our
family stability because all of this now
I could just sell at any time I'm
telling you right now that's a hundred
percent bull crap that's you flexing to
yourself giving yourself an excuse to
keep your toys because you know as well
as I do that covet comes along and stuff
shuts down or interest rates go way up
or I filled up my car just a minute ago
and two days ago when I left I've been
gone because I went to Texas for a
speaking event I came back gas is up
like 25 or 30 cents higher and I rented
a truck while I was in Texas and I got
home and said I'm gonna buy a truck when
I get back and then today I said thank
God I got this hybrid toilet that I
drive so you can say it all you want but
until you're holding that cash in your
hand none of that I could just none of
that's real it's not real it's not true
and so the I think I think Rachel's
question is instructive if you don't
care that you're just paying all this
money and interest and making other
people Rich then then I mean knock your
lights out man I'll still be your friend
we'll still hang out but if you are
ready to yeah be able to fish in it with
a boat that's paid off and drive a truck
that you don't owe money on dude change
your life man get your wife a house get
you all a house get some stability and
make yourself anti-fragile not just wait
until the next thing Falls over because
what's crazy John about just even your
numbers you just said yeah we live on
about you know 60 of our income so you
take that and so you're living on you
know 70 80 000 a year take the remaining
income sell your truck and you could be
completely debt free you're not even
using your truck you use your company
truck and the other one sits in the
garage as you're making payments on it
so like there's some smart things to do
here from a mathematical standpoint I'm
not even talking about the other side
the emotional side and all of that that
we talk a lot about on this show and how
much that frees you up but John like
from a mathematical standpoint if you
guys for one year live like you're
saying you live 60 which isn't even
sacrificial to y'all because that's just
how you live maybe you cut it even more
and it's 50 then take that 70 grand and
pay off the truck that's a hundred
thousand dollars and pay off the boat
pay off the student loans and start
investing start letting your money work
for you start actually trying to build
wealth than just sitting here making
payments and just kind of like living
the life do you know what I mean like
there's a really intentional plan that
you guys have the ability to walk down
but if you if the attitude is and I'm
not trying to pick on you but if the
attitude is like well we're kind of just
fine I don't think there's much you know
that we're going to be able to do
because the reason you called in was
asking about a house so my answer too
would be like no I would not use that 70
000 for a house I would use it to pay
off debt lower your income get this
stuff cleaned up and then you guys have
the ability to save up again for a down
payment on a house and you can start
moving that way after an emergency fund
so there's a way you can do it but it's
not going to just happen and
there's a part of Me John that thinks
like yeah you're I mean and some people
are at that place right I mean there's
what's your wife say about it
so she's kind of I mean she's on the
same page as me it's it's uh you know
the goal is to hopefully some point fish
for a living
um so but you know it so just goes back
to the to the first thing I saw I said
yeah it's either can we go ahead I mean
and get into it is it a good idea to go
ahead and get into that this house and
have home ownership and then start
working towards you know then paying
everything off or is someone going to
recommend hey go ahead and knock
everything out and then because then you
know kind of back to square one with
saving and it's part of it but um but
you're back that was just a question
you're back at square one but man I I
wouldn't quit my job to fish full-time
unless I didn't know anybody any money
if you don't owe anybody any money you
and your wife can take a risk like that
for a year hang on the line man
um October 19th through the 21st here in
Nashville is a marriage seminar we talk
about money and marriage and how to get
all wrapped up together I'm gonna give
you and your wife two free tickets it's
a 700 value it's gonna be on me it's
right down the street y'all come join us
and um we'll see if we can uh we'll be
friends and see what happens that's
right thanks for the call
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
uh the question of the day is sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
take your home's efficiency and style to
the next level with convenient solutions
from shelf Genie window Genie and glass
doctor visit neighborly.com to schedule
home services and professionals near you
I could use a visit from the Shelf Genie
shelves are great I know or a little
organization I need a lot of that all
right today's question comes from Katie
in Oregon Katie writes about seven years
ago my parents had asked me to get a
home together with him
at the time we were in an apartment with
a baby and our home buying option was
taking longer as my husband is
self-employed I said no many times but
after being asked over and over again my
husband and I agreed here I am seven
years later and miserable yes my parents
put the house in their name with only me
on the mortgage I'm not even on the deed
Oh Katie they tell me that I can't be on
the D due to the fact that they are over
65 and will say on taxes that's insane
my husband completely renovated the home
spending many thousands of dollars as
the house was falling apart when we
purchased it we pay 80 of the house
bills and whenever something happens we
fix it ourselves and put the time and
money into it at this point my parents
know I am unhappy but they have informed
me that if we decide to sell the house
they will be keeping most of the profit
because they are retired and will need
it whereas we are still young and
working
we have no money saved up because it has
been all spent in this home which has
led to some debt as well I feel like
we've been fixing a home that we simply
rent my parents of complete control
legally and financially I feel so
helpless lost and taken advantage of
that's it wow
well okay let's forget all the other
stuff let me just I'll just say this uh
Katie you have been taken advantage of
and you knew this was gonna happen you
knew it that's why you fought it for so
long because this kind of this kind of
these two your parents they didn't just
suddenly turn into this they've been
like this your whole life and you knew
this was a bad idea and you kept going
back because you had this imaginary
fantasy that one day we're all gonna be
one big happy family and they kept
saying well if we're gonna be a happy
family then you have to give us this
house and your parents hear me have
stolen from you
if they have used you taken from you and
stolen from you if I'm you I forget the
parents part now let's put the parent
part aside there's two adults who are
stealing from you robbing melting your
marriage and taking all of your money
for you and your small family I would
figure out whatever way I can get out of
this thing as quickly as possible if I
have to sue them possibly consider that
because they are stealing from you and
if not if you don't want to sue them
then you walk away with the loss you
walk away and learn your lesson and you
and your husband lick your wounds and
y'all go on the next I mean it's just
grosses me out I know at the beginning I
was trying to go back and reread did is
she living in the house with them yeah
yeah so they're all living in house yeah
so Katie I'd move out and I would be
done with it
um I would ask them yeah to get your
name off the mortgage if you need if
they need to refinance whatever they
have to do get your name I would I would
break this deal and if they won't pick
your name off the mortgage then you you
list the house for sale yeah because
you're I mean yeah I yeah that's the
number one thing and again I know
there's a lot of loss here from the
financial standpoint because you guys
have spent all of your savings all of
your debt and also though Katie like you
you and your husband have to take a look
in the mirror and be like wow we chose
this like we're adults we chose this for
seven years and we and we made this
decision so it it's a it's a complete
change not just from a financial living
perspective Katie but this is how you're
gonna basically View and what you're
communicating to your parents which is
the first time you've ever done it as
and you're an adult you're an adult and
this is what needs to happen because
John's right they've taken complete
Advantage you guys okay so John from
like a psychological standpoint when
parents do this maybe I'm very naive but
there's like that innate sense that
majority of and I know there's like
really toxic abusive situations right in
the world but parents like this Katie's
situation do they think that they're do
they know what they're doing or in their
minds this is the right thing like do
you know what I mean like is it
malicious for parents like this in this
type of relationship like do they know
what they're doing or in their like
Backwards Minds no no we're helping them
but no they're not I mean when they say
like if you sell it we're taking on it
all and like they know it's theirs right
um no I think what happens there there
becomes an a you owe me
like like I and I've heard this I bought
you groceries I made sure you always had
clothes and I did I you see me get irate
I don't ever get mad you know that I get
like that makes you they're your kid of
course like that wasn't an investment
that you were owed this back later with
interest right right I give you a house
for 18 years
yes
you made them into the world that's
right it is on you right right right so
there is a well I did this and so like
we just don't have anything because yeah
like you you gotta take care of your
parents and so it's I I don't want to go
down the diagnostic route
um but it's just a gross situation
because
whether you're six or whether you're 26
whether you're 46.
nobody wants to think my parents are are
preying on me right are using me right
and so you spend seven years 30 years
trying to fix that relationship because
somehow you think you're doing something
wrong because they would never do that
because they're your mom they're your
dad and it's a scary moment when
somebody like me tells you you have to
walk away because they're they're
they're going to kill you yeah right
they're robbing you blind yeah and it's
hard to like oh my gosh just shake that
reality Rachel no matter what happens in
your life whatever hell you go through
whatever terrible decisions you make
yeah there should always be two people
that you know the door is open if you if
you need somewhere to go and Katie has
learned the hard way that door's closed
she cannot go to them because they'll
steal from her and that's it that's a
soul-shaking bone rattling realization
for for folks yeah it's hard and then it
takes a situation like a messy house
situation
financially to wake up to that emotional
sense of oh my gosh this is the reality
my reality is my parents steal for me
yeah and they stealing from their
grandkid yeah my parents will steal from
their grandchild for their own
entitlement's sake what do you say to
people because I've heard you mentioned
it earlier I kind of go back to it
because I've heard a lot on this show
and even talking to people this sense of
it is my it's my responsibility it is my
duty to take care of my parents and if
they're 70 years old with no retirement
or whatever the situation is and we have
money like it is out I need to take care
of them because of you know what they
did and they're you know they're not
asking or maybe they are asking
for a for an adult child and their
parent relationship what does that look
like when the parents is the one that
needs help and the child child maybe can
provide but doesn't you don't need to
feel obligated in that like what what's
that boundary yeah I I probably have a
little bit different take on it I and I
can get all philosophical about it I
just know that if my mom was she's in
her 70s if my dad passed away and she's
like I have nothing I would have a sense
of obligation I got to figure something
I want to help her yes
um the two big things are number one me
and my household me and my wife me and
my kids we're whole we're good and so I
we put our oxygen mask on first we're no
good helping somebody else to your and
you die in the process doesn't help
anybody right so if you financially
can't if you are underwater and you
can't you don't have any money to give
and we've been on the show you and I
have been taking calls where someone's
like I need you to open up some credit
cards because I have to pay groceries
well she's 66 and doesn't want to I
don't care what she wants to She's Gotta
Eat that means she's gotta go work right
so number one you have to be whole and
number two you have to draw some
boundaries and that is not whatever they
want they want us to take over the
mortgage because they want to keep
living in this house
no they can move in the apartment down
the street from you where you live if
that's what y'all can afford with the
rent that's right right but they're
grown-ups and they can opt out of the
help I'm able and willing to provide but
it's going to come with some boundaries
so the first one is you got to be whole
and your marriage has to be good you all
have to be okay financially and two you
all have to sit down and say Here's what
we're willing to do or not do um it's
that that old honor your father mother
doesn't mean do whatever they say for as
long as they say even when it's abusive
or even when it's theft right right or
even when it's gonna crush your own
children that's not honoring your
household right yeah
um but it also means sorry old man you
should no I'm gonna help and take care
of my parents if I've got the means and
ability I'm gonna reach out yep because
I think that's what's so hard about
situations like this and Katie's like I
know it's a little different but but it
is that idea of like oh my gosh like
they are my parents but when the roles
reversed and you're in a better place
financially than your parents or even
emotional you're in a healthier place
and you're probably like it's weird when
that transition happens but it happens
for a lot of people those of you
listening maybe on the track of like
becoming debt free and having savings
all of it so you may find yourself in
that position of I'm so much better off
than my parents are what is my
obligation what does that role look like
so that's so helpful John thanks so much
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Dr John
deloney and John you mentioned this in
the first segment but you and I are kind
of co-headlining entire weekend events I
am your opener always will be Rachel
Rachel Cruz is headlining I'm the man
I'm the main act and I'm open John's
opening uh for money and marriage and
that is going to be in October uh and we
are so excited about this it's going to
be a full weekend event and so you can
go to ramseysolutions.com and yeah get
all the information there because uh
it's it's a it's going to be a full
packed weekend October 19th through the
21st and we've we're going over content
now we've been planning this for for
weeks now we've had a lot of
conversations behind closed doors this
is a very unreimsy event right yes it's
a it's a weekend thing we're talking
about sex we're talking about money
we're talking about like it will be a a
deep deep dive we'll have special guests
come and join us yep um and we'll have a
ton of fun with and we're in Nashville
so there's always gonna be surprises and
we'll have a prom one night it'll be a
blast it's gonna be good it's gonna be
fun you guys so again this is going to
be more an event I'll say this for
people baby steps you know four five six
and Beyond uh because it is a little bit
of a higher ticket price but it's a
it's full days where you're diving into
a lot of content you're gonna get
um it's just a it's a really fun
experience because it's two subjects
that I think are really difficult for
people and so we're gonna bring
hopefully a lot of instruction but also
it's gonna be fun Clarity we're gonna
have a lot of fun yeah so again go to
ramseysolutions.com
events for the money and marriage
weekend events I thought it was super
expensive I thought 699 799 was a
bajillion dollars and then everyone I've
talked to that has ever put on an event
like this they were like you undersold
by half what do you do totally I didn't
get on to me about it we're used to like
evening events like building Wells that
will hit you know different cities and
so this being longer event and all of it
yeah maybe to us we're like yeah
come to Nashville hang out for a weekend
have a blast that's right absolutely all
right coming up next we got Thomas in
Columbia South Carolina Hey Thomas
welcome to the show
hey how's it going how are y'all good
what's up man
hey yeah so uh just some background
information uh to start off with um I'm
30 years old uh working a okay I.T job
I'm making about 42k
um I have around like 35k debts it's a
primarily student loan at five and a
half I have about like 9k in savings
and not much in retirement right now
but my question for you guys
is essentially how am I supposed to
follow the baby steps
when I'm constantly struggling with ADHD
because it seems like it's virtually
impossible to maintain stick with these
long-term goals such as this especially
when the literature shows that stuff
like this is very difficult for
neurodivergent people
well I've lived in that literature
because I am that person and so on the
other side of it I can tell you it's
possible because I'm sitting here
and um I think if you Google the
Wikipedia page for ADHD my face comes up
on it and so
um here's how I've chosen to look at it
um
number one at is not a stamp or an
identity or a this is a a death sentence
if you will a a in stone this is the
path that you will go on
for me it's a helpful piece of
information about how my body and brain
respond to stress and chaos
and how my brain and body respond to
some daily
um stimulus
and so I have to do the broader work
which is to create a world in a context
where
um
I'm able to function and do what I need
to do so I want you to to to stamp this
sentence on your soul that I'm about to
give you it is a context not an excuse
it might be harder for you to do certain
things it might be harder for you to
stick with certain things
and that means you're going to have to
work harder than the average person or
someone who's more neurotypical to
create boundaries for you and to create
plans and accountability for you so that
you get to the end
absolutely so when I say that does that
does that hurt your feelings does that
Empower you because when I change the
way I thought about it I felt like I was
a laser beam instead of I was I was at
the mercy of this thing
no I mean I totally get what you're
saying it's it's trying to I see I see
it as like a way of like shifting your
mentality towards the whole the whole
notion of it yeah but it's bigger than
that because I think we have a way of a
whole culture that's about manifesting
and just change your change your mindset
you can't do that with ADHD that's the
issue is the mindset yeah is the
challenge so what I have to do I have to
powerfully invest in discipline I have
to do the same thing every day over and
over especially when I don't want to
when I don't feel like I can and I also
have to create gaps so that on those
days it is just maniacal and chaotic
um that I've got space enough that I'm
still going to get to work on time and
I'm still going to and there's been
Seasons I've talked about on the show
there's been Seasons especially old John
I would give my debit card to my wife
I was out of control and so I began to
put huge hurdles between me and
decisions that were going to get me in
trouble when I was being impulsive
um and then as I went down the
literature with ADHD and recognized diet
and sleep and counseling and significant
exercise in shifting my life way
Upstream my ADHD symptoms the day-to-day
hell that was living with that has
transformed my friend transformed right
right how's your overall life in that
way Thomas when he when he kind of says
all of that uh do you feel like you have
a grip on all of that
uh I mean some days are better than
others I mean no doubt but um I mean
I've been dealing with it like you know
ever since I was little so it's just you
know a constant ongoing battle so why
are you working a job that you don't
like that doesn't honor you
it's not that it no it doesn't honor me
it's just a job that I can tolerate
because I have skills in that area but
one of the one of the magic Parts one of
the super powers of somebody who is is
struggles with ADHD is the ability to
laser in on something
like nobody else
yeah hyper focusing that's right so what
are the things that bring you hyper
focus in your life
for me I found it it was sitting with
hurting people which is a strange thing
but everything shut off when I sat in
this in the sewer with somebody who was
hurting
and I began to build a world around okay
I can that my body locks in when that
happens what's that thing for you
I mean honestly like I got into what I'm
doing now because of my my desire my
passion for technology when I was
younger
and I feel like I don't know as I'm
getting older and you know experiencing
you know the real world so to say uh I
feel part of that has died
to a degree and so let me tell you this
I could be
um helping people as a professional
licensed counselor I could go get my
certification go sit with people eight
hours a day or ten hours a day seven
days a week and that would slowly burn
me out
I could go back to being a dean of
students which is the way I could sit
with hurting people and help folks but
also I had a whole bunch of other things
what you have done is you've allowed a
job to see that's that's
um the minutia of the particular role
you took in technology which is the
thing that brought you Joy and Hyper
focus and laser beam
you've taken one role and let it suck
your soul and you said well this is just
growing up that's Blink 182 says it's
not you're just not in the right gig
right if you're good at programming
you're good at I.T I don't care what you
do forty two thousand dollars is about
half your market value
no doubt and so a gift for somebody with
ADHD is connection other people
people looking at you and thinking you
have value and working on projects not
just in jobs working on projects that
you're like yes I want to solve this
problem and that's when ADHD has become
a super power for folks myself included
yeah that's so good John so I I would I
would stay on the line because we're
going to send you Ken Coleman's get
clear assessment and I want you to look
at that and begin to ask yourself about
not technology but ask yourself about
problems that you want to be working on
and solving people you want to be
helping yeah and the challenge too
Thomas of looking at that job because
when you up your income as you called
back to getting on track with the baby
steps you know that thousand dollar
emergency fund you have is starting to
work to pay off that debt like what are
systems in place financially that can
keep you on track and keep you focused
and maybe get smaller goals day to day
or week to week versus the big 18 you
know 24 month goals but finding what
works for you Thomas but I think a big
confidence boost would be looking into
the marketplace and see what you're
worth and see if you can get your income
up thanks for the call
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey show we are
taking your calls America it's a free
call anywhere in the country at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
up next we have forest in Houston Texas
hey Forrest welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely
oh nothing much man hey so I am a newly
found Dave ramzonian and um
I love the title it's a very houstonian
thing to say
yeah I've been listening for about a
week and a half and you know before I
started listening I really thought that
I was in a good place financially but
the more I listen the more I realized
that I really might not be
um so I am planning on proposing to my
girlfriend here in the next couple of
months congratulations dude do it do it
on on the air do it right now let's call
it
Boris I won't let you I would not let
you Forrest I got engaged in a Papacitos
in Houston
everything else was a disaster do it
better than I did man it was not it was
not great it was embarrassing oh man
that's funny well uh um so
so my question is I have a 26 000 car
note on well short note
um and she has about
my girlfriend has about 44 000 in
student loan payments
um since I started listening to y'all a
week and a half ago I've paid all my
student loans off I have oh my gosh way
to go man well done how much was that
about five grand but I just wanted to
get it out of the way
um I make so I'll get into some numbers
for y'all I make about 130 000 I'm 25
years old
um and God man what do you do
I'm a field sales engineer
um I sell electronic components for a
electronic component manufacturer I work
with companies Engineers to get our
parts specked into their new like
prototype builds so I don't know any of
the words you just said but
congratulations man that's awesome
that's really great man
thank you so
um I guess what my question is
um I want to get my car note and her
debt paid off as quickly as possible and
being in field sales I am driving
um I'm drive everywhere I mean I go have
five or six customer calls at different
locations every single day so I'm on the
road constantly and I drive a truck
so looking back I don't think it was the
best purchase but I'm wondering if I
should just sell it and get like a
hybrid or a little car with a lot better
gas mileage and put that money towards
um
towards like my car note and her student
loans or if y'all think I should just
pay it off as quickly as possible and
then start tackling her student loans
um okay well I'll say this first and
foremost for us I would not tackle her
student loans until you guys are married
we've taken sadly a good number of calls
on this show where couples combine
finances before they're married and he
pays off her loans six months down the
road in the engagement
it ends and they're off right and and
that money was you know I hate to say
wasted but for that person individual
was wasted yeah I know that when she
just said that you just were like yeah
Rachel I would not have jobs if
everybody's plans always worked out yeah
so when you guys say I do and you're
driving to the reception you can log on
online and pay it all off that moment
but not until you are legally married do
you need to pay on anyone's debt or uh
even combine finances so I'll just say
that as a quick like overshot uh but for
you and your truck do you like the truck
yeah I I love it but looking back it was
just one of those things where I'm like
I finally finished school I'm making a
good intern yeah I wanna I wanna I did
the exact same thing dude yeah so I mean
honestly for us with your income this
the debt you could pay off the truck and
be fine but if you're looking at it as
an overall just an experiential idea
because of you drive a lot and you're
like oh my gosh I could have a hybrid
and save on gas like it would be a
different play then yeah I would sell
the truck uh save up some money buy some
buy a hybrid buy something that you know
gas mileage wise because you drive so
much is more efficient to your lifestyle
then you could do that too but but the
numbers you know some people call and
we're like sell the truck sell the truck
sell the car because their debt is half
of their annual income or or their
annual income we've gotten that call
before so because of your income is so
high you could buckle down and just pay
it off but if you don't want the truck I
would Kelly Blue Book it and see what
you get for the difference save some
money on the side forest and then yeah
get a used car for now and then kind of
work your way up and keep stepping up in
car but I wouldn't go get another car
loan on a hybrid though
right and I I did check Kelly Blue Book
I mean I owe about 25 000 on it saying I
could get around 36. oh my gosh you
would make money on it you should have
seen Dave Ramsey's face when he found
out the guy he had just hired I was
driving a Prius for that very reason and
he was like what and then I totaled the
Prius and I upgraded to drum roll please
the most masculine car you can drive a
Highlander but I live far away and so
I'm like like the gas mileage part and
I've driven a truck my whole adult life
and I love trucks and I'll have one
again but right now it just makes sense
so I think what Rachel said is that
that's less of a financial thing and
it's more of a is this is this make
sense for the job I have and for the gas
mileage that I've got I think and
everyone's just got to make that choice
but dude if I was you right now I'd sell
that truck right now yeah I'd save up 10
grand and buy a 20 000 hybrid and be off
to the race do you have any cash Forest
yeah I have well that's that's another
thing so I I don't know
let's just say something happens to my
truck I know that the baby steps day to
save up one thousand dollars but let's
let's just say my transition goes out
I'm one of those people that has ten
thousand dollars in like my emergency
fund just because it puts me at a better
in a better headspace I I just I don't
know that that the cash is costing you
money
okay
yeah okay so I need to just when you
have twenty thousand dollars at seven
percent interest that you're paying out
and you're have ten thousand dollars in
the bank at two percent you're you're
that it's costing you five percent of
that money for a peace of mind which and
I'll give you some of that but
part of that thousand dollars is to is
you should be uncomfortable you should
be like I don't have enough if something
really goes wrong you're exactly right
you don't and it's it's supposed to Spur
you on to get this crap knocked out so
how much you have saved for us you have
10 grand
yes ma'am okay so if you can sell your
car for 36 you owe 25 you'll have eleven
thousand dollars to replace your car you
have ten Grand which is your three to
six months of expenses that you're
starting to save and then you go yeah so
you're fine the car is the piece that or
the truck God lead Force I would
probably just sell it by the end of the
week make money on it use that
difference go get a used car it's not
gonna be as fun as your truck for a
little bit but that's okay you're just
driving it and put miles on it uh you
got your 10 grand in the bank as your
three to six months of expenses and then
I would start saving cash and when you
guys set a date for for getting married
and and her what what does she make she
has 44 000 in student loans what does
she make
well so she's kind of in between jobs
right now so she was working as a
purchasing agent for a manufacturing
company but she has decided that she
wants to um she wants to get her
teaching certification so she's gonna
start teaching here in December
um
and another thing that I didn't even
mention is we're we're going to be
moving my job transitioned me to the DFW
area so
um we're just kind of in a transition
period right now yeah okay so then I
mean if I were you guys I again the
whole truck thing sell but anyway get 11
Grand go buy another car have the 10
okay and then you're I mean you're a
single guy right now I'm making 130 I
would just pile cash dude yeah because
you guys are gonna be saving for a
wedding you're saving for a Transit a
move uh knowing your future wife has
some debt that you're probably going to
be paying online after you guys yeah
after you guys get married so like you
have a lot of stuff happening right now
so if I were you get rid of the truck
payment
save save save save save save save for
us and you'll have a pile of money in
the bank which is amazing to be able to
use for all this transition that's
coming up but it's really exciting I'm
so glad you're a a new listener because
you guys man it is uh
um what are the chances she listens to
this show
well she hasn't yet but okay listen
listen we're right up against the clock
so listen I've Rachel and I are hosting
a money and marriage Retreat October
19th to the 21st
if I gave you two tickets would you
propose on stage it would make for our
show to be awesome here in Nashville
I'm gonna put that pressure
no it would make for a great show no she
would love him forever if I got engaged
on a on an event you would yes you fun
Ruiner it would have been awesome all
right guys stay on the light stay in the
line if you want a forest thank you guys
thanks America for listening thanks to
everyone in the booth for helping out
thank you John for making this crazy
this is the Ramsey Show
it's Rachel Cruz if you show and want a
deeper dive on your money Journey we
have a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we've helped people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships I am
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz hosting
this hour with my good friend and fella
Ramsay personality Dr John deloney and
we are here to answer your calls a free
call anywhere in the country at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and up first this hour we have Emily in
uh Tacoma Washington that's a beautiful
place Emily welcome to the show
thank you hey Emily hold on one second
is that where you just saw Taylor Swift
in Tacoma no it was in Seattle a little
bit outside of it but but I was up in
the Pacific Northwest it's my husband's
favorite part of the country Emily she
was a part of the Taylor Swift
earthquake recently true story
all right so what's up true story
so I have been listening to the show and
as well as Dr John deloney's show for
years
um but my husband and I have been living
paycheck to paycheck and using credit
cards to fill in gaps
um fast forward to today I'm pregnant
with baby number two to do at the
beginning of November congratulations
thank you
um and I'm four months into uh intensive
EMDR therapy
um just surrounding my childhood trauma
um and it feels like a fog has been
lifted and I'm seeing our situation more
clearly and now I'm just terrified and
don't know the right right way out of uh
the mess that we've created financially
can I just tell you that that's uh EMDR
is tough and I that's a courageous move
on your part I'm really proud of you
like for real and you're pregnant now
you've been you've been going through
that for the last few months
yeah yeah that will have
that will have dividends on your child's
nervous system that's growing inside of
you like what you've done is is
literally changing your family tree I'm
so proud of you it's amazing thank you
thank you and so so I remember one time
uh I was doing some hard trauma
counseling and a few months later my
counselor asked me
um and you may have heard me talk about
this on my show she asked me like what
do you feel and I said I feel like my
marriage is great my kids are great my
job is awesome I don't know how to say
this but objectively if I was just to go
down the list
I would I would tell you I feel
depressed I feel like I'm running low
and she smiled real big and said this is
you for the first time
since you can remember that you're not
in fight or flight and she smiled and
goes this is what normal feels like and
you're gonna have to practice living
like this without being amped up and
fighting and running all the time and I
want to tell you it's been the best
living like falling asleep at night
because it's because I'm tired right
those kind of moments and so I tell you
all that to tell you as you begin to
heal
reality sets in right and for me that
reality was after 15 years of running
and screaming and fighting everybody and
running and trying to achieve everything
I got a good marriage I got a good job I
got a good life but also in your case
that could like the smoke can clear the
fog lifted as you said and you could
realize Whoa We owe a lot of money and
we are living paycheck to paycheck and
we're making some daily and weekly and
monthly choices that have to be
different or maybe my marriage isn't
what I want it to be or what I thought
it would be and so I think now you're in
a place where your body is telling you
okay now we have some real things to be
scared of in the present right and with
trauma like your body's responding in
the present to things that happened in
the past well now we've got some real
things in the present and so now I want
you to do this I want you to be really
curious about what your body's trying to
get your attention for and I hope you
hear my voice on purpose like huh what
are you trying to tell me so as you say
I'm scared tell me what you're scared of
what's your body trying to get your
attention about
um we just we don't have anything in
savings okay and we have about 33 000
and
um you know credit cards and we have a
truck and then we also have a mortgage
on top of that what they'll do for a
living
so I work for uh city government and my
husband's a carpenter okay how much you
guys make
um we he is unemployed for portions of
the year so
um we've been making about a hundred
thousand a year why does he choose to be
unemployed for parts of the year
um you know I don't know so if I was a
Gambling Man
and I'm terrible at gambling so I don't
really ever do it but if I was a
Gambling Man I would suggest to you that
a big alarm system that's going off in
your body is you are Tethered to
somebody that you don't feel safe with
and maybe not feel safe because he
doesn't hit you or doesn't scream or run
around on you but he is not providing in
a way that makes any sense to you and
you're a pregnant mother of one about to
be two you're working a full-time job
and he's sitting at home going I don't
know I don't know
is that is that does that ring a bell
yeah yeah
sounds like that's the place to start
yeah
that's what we find Emily is so often we
say on this show and it ends up being
really true is that our money problems
are just the symptom of other things
going on and so
um so I think yeah you addressing that
have you have you addressed concerns
with him in a very clear way that
your thoughts or you just kind of now
coming to this reality as you're calling
us
um yeah we've talked about it and he
agrees with it and
he understands the Dave Ramsey plan and
wants to go along with it but then when
it comes to actually like making a
budget and sticking to it that's where
you know I get left alone well
there's a step beneath the Dave Ramsey
plan that he's not buying into and that
is I'm going to work to provide for my
family
and take care of my family yeah he's not
honoring his wife and he's not honoring
his two kids
because he takes off half the year
and I I was just in Texas
um this past a couple days ago for a
speaking event and I went to visit my
friend who works maintenance at a
university and he's one of the greatest
guys in the world his name is Gustavo
and I went to visit him after move-in
day it's a thousand degrees in Texas and
I went to visit him after move-in day
when the maintenance guys are up from 4
30 in the morning until 4 pm at night
and I knocked on his door I haven't seen
him in a decade and his wife said oh
he's working he's at UPS right now
that's a guy that's working to take care
of his family
right he went after a job that would
have buried all of us and then he went
to his other job that would have buried
all of us
it was such a you see I'm saying like
that's that's taking care of your family
your husband's not doing that and then
the Dave Ramsey stuff like racy yeah he
just
um he's not he's not a person of
integrity at that point yeah so the
conversation Emily I would have with him
is not well we're not doing the Dave
Ramsey I can't breathe it's I I'm scared
I'm scared and it's that's to the point
when that isn't answered and a couple
can't look at each other and say okay
how are we going to do this journey
together and lock arms and figure out
Solutions which could be the Dave Ramsey
plan but when you're not willing to do
that that's when the marital issues
really come to light and that's when I
would say what bring in a third party
right now therapy to get your marriage
in a healthy spot and then looking at
your finances but in the meantime EMily
doing what you can of yeah creating a
budget not going in the whole
financially is the Band-Aid to kind of
keep you afloat but the bigger picture
here I think is that marriage piece so
we'd encourage you to go forward I would
hang on the line Emily because Austin
will pick up and I want to give you guys
Financial Peace University if you guys
can sit down and go through a few of
these lessons together I think it may be
really helpful to start the conversation
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show if you
are a new listener and you're hearing us
you know say words like the baby steps
or the debt snowball and this plan about
getting in control of your money and you
might be a little confused I would
encourage you to really get a deeper
dive into the Ramsay plan so if you'll
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button and we're going
to help you figure out the next best
step for your financial Journey so it's
a it's a it's a great tool there to kind
of say hey if you're starting out where
are you what do you need to do next and
that again is at ramsaysolutions.com get
started click that button and we want to
help walk with you through your
financial journey I am Rachel Cruz
hosting the show today with Dr John
deloney taking your calls about money
life relationships anything and
everything we're here for you so next up
we have Adam in Phoenix hey Adam welcome
to the show
hello how are you we are doing great
so um
my wife and I we have quite a bit of
debt
um and so I was wondering how we should
start working through that you have
about 150 in car loans and about 280 in
student loans 115 and car loans
uh one five zero 150 in carlands
okay about 75 on each okay and uh it's
been about 280 in student loans okay
um so when I called in with this Greener
I said we have quite a bit in home
equity
so I was curious
um is that something that would be on
the table the seller house and just
basically wipe it all out one Fell Swoop
or actually work our way through that
yeah it's a good that's a a good
question
um Adam how much you guys make a year
uh net combines about 330. okay
and for the home how much do you how
much do you owe on it how much is left
on the mortgage
um about 3.85. okay and how much would
it sell for
um probably near eight
okay and why do you have 150 000 in cars
I guess you make 330. so I guess that
works what kind of cars do you all Drive
uh well you guys the BMW is one of them
yeah and uh another one is a newer truck
yeah I mean I would expect nice cars
yeah if you're making 330 yeah well for
yeah 150 000 hopefully you're not saying
a Honda Civic like I would I would like
assume I mean I would assume like yeah
but it goes something it makes that cool
Noise Okay so Adam
um do you guys have any money in savings
do you have any cash
yeah we do how much you have um
all right right now we have about 10
we're waiting on
um
about 30
000 to come in and what do you what is
it what do you mean waiting on what does
that mean
uh for for an invoice okay okay like so
that'll be thirty thousand dollars cash
to you
correct okay
um no you don't need to sell so no you
don't need to sell your house
um I can kind of just dive into it
because you guys how old are you guys
Adam
um I am 41 and my wife is 32. okay do
you guys have kids
yes one one kid okay before Rachel says
that you're the richest broke guy I've
talked to in a while
does that ring true
I guess you make way too much money to
be this broke
I I agree with you 100 yeah okay yeah so
Adam Rachel I'll give you the path
so I need like I need you to like
realize because here's the deal yeah you
could sell your home take four hundred
thousand dollars wipe this all clean but
Adam and his wife are Gonna Keep on
Living their life the way they have
there's gonna be no change in this
process and mathematically you don't
need to sell your house you guys just
need to get your crap together and you
would also sell your house to pay off
two degrees depreciating assets yeah
that doesn't make any sense man yeah no
no so I would I would stay put in the
home and you guys Adam I mean like I
there's something about you all at this
point that I'm like I want you to feel a
level of sacrifice so with this debt I
mean because you have 280 in student
loans you can't afford these cars at
them so I'm selling them I mean I'm I'm
gonna get rid of them use some of this
10 grand to buy you know or wait for the
30 grand to come in spend 15 grand on
two cars and again they're not going to
be BMWs in a nice truck like you're
going to have a lifestyle shock factor
to you all but I think you kind of need
it Adam you guys make a lot of money
you have a lot of debts and something
has to change your formula is not
working would you agree
I agree 100 yeah so I mean I think
that's kind of been the realization
um yeah
and y'all as of recently you know yeah
and I'm like man you know you're 41 and
I know we can't go back in time there's
a part of me wish that you were 25 so
I'd be like clean this up and you're
like gonna go so at 41 it's even that
much more urgent to be like Adam you
guys make insane money like you could do
really well but if you keep living like
this you're not going to like you work
too hard and you've worked too hard
to have nothing to have 280 in student
loan debt and a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in cars like
like that I wouldn't want to make three
you know 3 30 and that be my life right
so like there has to be something that
majorly changes so if I woke up in your
shoes Adam
I would sit down and I would say all
right we're in Phoenix we make 380. how
do we live on 75 grand next year like
let's just chow and that's still a
really great salary there's a lot of
people that wish they made 75 000 like
what if we just took majority of our
income sold the cars paid off the debt I
mean all this could be turned around in
a year at them and you still have your
house with your equity
yeah
yeah I agree and um personally I've been
looking at ways to maybe even increase
our income
you can't I just think y'all freaking
need to cut your lifestyle you can't be
just like hanging out going on vacations
all the time it's just also just for a
minute for a year for a year that's all
you got to do I wouldn't up your income
you guys have an amazing income I think
it's your lifestyle if we look at this
right now it's uncomfortable is that 18
months you go from making 3 30 and owing
three to four hundred thousand to yeah
owing nobody anything it is 30 grand
coming in too remember that half a
million dollars in equity in your house
like you you flip things around so fast
so fast you all could be in a completely
millionaire in 48 months like the whole
thing rolls over but you just gotta say
never do it you just gotta do it
gotcha
all right um I just kind of
quasi-familiar with you guys baby steps
and whatnot um okay so so
um oh this is gonna make you real
uncomfortable man it's gonna be so well
what it is Adam I mean like honestly I'm
like I would and and the baby steps is
this I'm like I I would it's a thousand
dollar emergency fund so you so you
freed up in our math right now you freed
up nine Grands from the 10 grand that
you have let's say the the 30 comes in
you got 39 Grand to use okay you sell
your cars
I wonder how much I wonder if you Kelly
Blue booked on what you would do because
you're going to lose money on them
you're going to owe some money probably
on it
um get some beaters and then with your
income again I'm like golly and yeah in
12 months Adam you're paying off your
debt smallest to largest but I would get
rid of the cars and so the only debt you
have left is that 280 in a student loans
and you guys start just throwing
everything at it everything and yeah and
working extra I mean I kind of was like
no you don't need your income yeah sure
work actually like do whatever you guys
can to get out of the 280 as fast as
possible but if I were you all if I woke
up in your shoes the first place I'm
cutting is lifestyle which is the most
painful and not in the most not fun
right you've been y'all been going out
to eat going on vacations with friends I
mean I can only imagine your lifestyle
and I bet it's great and so fun but
nothing oh we have and I'm not going to
deny that at all I mean yeah we work so
hard to get to that point in life yeah
and then
my wife graduated and then we were like
well we're here let's enjoy it and
that's normal Adam yeah you're not crazy
yeah that that is normal it's all of us
but also your results are normal and
normal is broke right so you're waking
up to the fact like oh my gosh we're
just like everybody else everything
looks great but we literally don't have
an I mean we don't have much of a net
worth even though we make 330 000 a year
you know so it's that really simple
mindset but Adam
um yeah stay on the line and I'm Gonna
Give You Total Money Makeover it's one
of our best-selling books when it comes
to just the baby steps you can read it
in a night it's a really easy read but
walk through this process with your wife
because again I'm so encouraged by your
numbers you guys could have an insane
life that's all yours and not tied to
the bank anymore but you guys have to
make that decision thanks for the call
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
you guys we are giving cash away and you
could win one of our 500 weekly prizes
or the grand prize of three thousand
dollars so to increase your chances you
can enter every single day you can enter
daily at ramseysolutions.com giveaway
and you can also get our best-selling
books like The Total Money Makeover from
paycheck to purpose and own your pass
change your future for as low as 12
also you can pre-order John who's
sitting right next to me his brand new
book building a non-anxious life and
you'll learn the six daily choices to
break free from a life spinning out of
control plus if you pre-order today for
just twenty dollars you can get seventy
five dollars and free bonus items and
questions for humans that John also did
is there in the store for 12 as well so
we're giving away cash lots of deals
going on if you go to
ramseysolutions.com store and John your
book I'm really excited about building a
non-exist live because
um your last book you did on anxiety was
a shorter version of it we call it a
quick read around here so
um but it sold insane and so obviously
we all know anxiety depression all of
this is a topic in our world today and
it's becoming more and more of a
conversation and so being able to write
a book and have things in words inside
of it to give people hope and also
instruction and this idea of hey this is
maybe what's going on and so here's what
to do acknowledge it and all that so
yeah I'm kind of excited to reached a
point just in my personal life
everybody's talking about it yeah and
it's almost like the David and Goliath
story like everybody's just talking
about look over there look over there
look over there and finally a kid comes
out and he's like I'll I'll fight him
and it it kind of feels that way like
everybody's talking about it all these
experts have been telling me I've been a
part of that crew like well you should
all do this as I push my glasses up my
nose right right and we have to look
around and say okay what we're what
we're doing is not working yeah and that
really set me on a rabbit rabbit down a
rabbit hole like what is what are we
doing and so this this book is as as
direct as possible and it's you and me
sitting down
here's here's just the truth of where we
found ourselves and here's here's the
most important thing here's what you can
do yes oh it gives us like a power back
yeah that's so good so again building a
non-anxious life and it's pre-sale you
guys so go ahead and order because
you'll get some free stuff and just kind
of that peek into that publishing author
world if you know pre-sales helps so
much because on the day the book
launches which is why October third
third all those sales hit that day which
means possibly hitting bestseller lists
getting other people whether it's Media
or just people chatting about the book
so it gets the book in front of more
people and that's the goal so it's like
hey we want you to know this message
hear this message read this message that
John has because if you even if you
listen to a show you know he's one of
the best at being able to empathize take
people's real life situations and walk
them through it so building a
non-anxious life if you go to
ramseysolutions.com you can pre-order
today all right up next we have
Elizabeth in Savannah Georgia hey
Elizabeth welcome to the show
hello I'm so excited to be talking to
you guys oh we're glad you called how
can we help
so I think
um we are in baby steps uh five and six
my husband and I
um and was hoping to get some clarity on
if we should invest uh some of money
into our home or into our children's
uh College savings and I can provide
some more details to okay give you why
it's a question yeah yeah well go ahead
go ahead and yeah throw some numbers out
so
um my husband is in the Army so it's
easiest to give you a monthly uh salary
amount our take-home pay after our 15 in
retirement and taxes and everything is
about 13 200 between our two incomes and
um we own a house in Florida and a house
in Savannah
um and we are currently renting out the
house in Florida and so I included that
income
um in that number I just gave you and I
also
um acquired quite a bit of a single
stock throughout my entire life it was a
gift for my grandfather every birthday
every Christmas and after listening to
you guys decided to sell it uh because
it's not the best place to keep money
just in case you know something happens
to that stock yeah so we have about
after taxes thirty thousand dollars to
contribute to either our children's
education or the ha one of the houses is
what we were planning on
um and my question is what should we do
for my current daughter who's already
born and on this world we have the
Florida College Savings Program set up
for her and I am expecting baby number
two next week oh my gosh congratulations
Elizabeth thank you so much wondering if
um we should do another Florida College
savings plan we would be able to just
pay it in full
um for her we wouldn't have to do any
payment plan or anything because of this
thirty thousand dollars but since we
also have the GI Bill accessible to my
husband we were wondering if that would
be a redundant use of the funds
um
and then because we have the GI Bill if
it would just make more sense to put
into the home
sure okay so the Florida
um the Florida plan is that basically
prepaid tuition
for the State of Florida yes so you're
um you're guaranteed four years
um at a university but if they don't go
to Florida school you get a payout value
of
um 63.5 okay and you guys have you done
that with your first
your first child so that's done so their
college is done and especially if they
go to a Florida school they're covered
correct okay and so then you have
another child on the way how much do you
owe on the house
um the Florida house we owe
um 153 000. okay
um and it is worth
um about 320 according to Zillow okay
and our Savannah house we owe uh 220 and
it's worth 330 according to Zillow okay
um in this Florida house I'm assuming
you need residents there for the
education that you set up does that does
that handcuff you guys to this house is
this one of the main reasons you're
keeping it or do you use the house
what's this Florida house for you guys
why'd you buy it um honestly we were
stationed there when my husband was
stationed there I gotcha and
um
it's been very lucrative for us as a
rental property it also does provide our
residency we are considered Florida
residents so even though we live in
Georgia we don't pay state taxes in
Georgia because of military benefits so
it is something we want to hold on to
because of those those benefits we also
do Envision ourselves moving back to
Florida after military is through okay
and moving back to that home
specifically
oh maybe maybe not okay to be determined
yeah um I know you all do not promote
um
rental properties that have debt on them
yes
um which I learned since since we've
made the purchase no it's good it's also
in other states too just and it's just
about I just imagine you your husband's
out on exercises for nine weeks and
you've got two toddlers and then some
your neighbor in Florida calls you and
says that your renters trash the place
or one of their cousins came over and
just went bananas and so we did yes and
I totally agree with you and hear you we
do have a property manager that we've
been really fond of we met them through
church
um and they've been taking good care of
the property
um and even after paying them we're
still
um about 700 a month above our mortgage
payment and take-home pay so right now
it hasn't felt like a burden in any way
um
but I do I definitely hear you all
um and it's something I've discovered
you all since my husband he's deployed
right now okay so would you ever
consider selling your house in Georgia
and renting there until you until the
the service was up
um
maybe we're probably due to move within
the next year so that's it probably
wouldn't make sense for us to rent
um for that short of time but when we
move it's definitely not off the table
okay so what I the way I answer these
calls Elizabeth always is if I were if I
were to wake up in your shoes having a
baby in six days and all that um I your
kids are young enough right now that I
wouldn't be like as concerned about the
college thing I mean personally which I
know throws off the tuition and I know
you guys want to keep the Florida
residents and all of it but if I'm a mom
I'm a toddler new baby there's a part of
me that just wants to get out of the
Florida house you're gonna make enough
and that 30 grand from your stock that
within like golly two years you guys
could be completely debt free paying off
your Georgia home and then from there
decide hey do we want rental property
somewhere what do we want to do because
you have time with the kids college to
be able to fund that because I think
that is an important step but right now
gosh I would I would like but I thought
or I would sell that house so I hope
that helps Elizabeth thanks for the call
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour Dr John
deloney and it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and up next we have Mark in Charlotte
North Carolina hey Mark welcome to the
show
good afternoon Rachel oh thank you so
much for taking my call absolutely how
can we help
well I'm recently divorced
um I just finished uh Financial
mediation on yesterday uh where we
agreed that I would give my ex uh 50k
from the equity of the home
um she is not on the mortgage I'm on the
mortgage alone and I have a really good
interest rate 2.62 and at the moment I'm
not going to refinance or uh sell the
home so I'm interested in what is the
best way to give my ex the fifty
thousand dollars in equity that oh shoot
rates
um yeah I mean there's some options are
you where are you at with your finances
do you have debt do you have savings
well I'm currently I was currently on
baby step three uh but I feel like I'm
gonna be going back to baby step one
because I I feel like I'm gonna have to
take out a personal loan to give it to
her because I'm not willing to refinance
at the moment or I'm I'm not considering
it okay and what's causing you not to
reconsider it
would you rather take out a personal
loan
the time frame um I have to give her the
50K by September 1st
um and like in two weeks yes
yeah I mean I've it and I I'm I'm
answering your question I'm talking to
Rachel
um I've heard Dave tell people to go
grab go take out a loan and go pay make
this thing be over
the business Arrangement that was your
former marriage
and put that 50k in baby step two so you
would be going backwards how much do you
have saved in your baby step three right
now
about four thousand okay how much do you
make a year
oh after taxes it's a 96 or about 129
before taxes okay
um
yeah I mean at this at this rate and
especially with the time frame I mean
that's yeah extreme extremely quick
um I feel like yeah I mean there's not
you don't really have many options with
that I was thinking of yeah do you look
for a home I mean you know do you need
the house I'm just trying to find ways
other pieces to this puzzle but
honestly the urgency of the time frame I
mean that's in
10 days so yeah I mean I think that
taking out a personal loan is going to
have to be your only option right now
and then you are going to go back
to baby step two and I would just pay it
off obviously as as fast as you can you
may have to even roll and I don't even
know if you can find a 50 000 unsecured
loan unless you go get a HELOC
do you have any equity
I'm sorry they said you you do qualify
for it
yes I've called around to um all the
financial institutions and um Credit
Unions that I partnered with and I've
got some good quotes
um on top of the 50 000 I was actually
considering taking out
17 000 actually uh 50 000 to pay my ex
ten thousand to pay my attorneys and
then any like maintenance or uh upgrades
I need to make to the house once I get
back because it has been years since
I've even been back to the hospital and
listen dude this is why we tell people
never borrow money because it it opens a
Floodgate that it's so hard to not and
so
like it I think I've been on I I don't
know how many episodes I've done here
but I think I've talked to 6 000 callers
I can't I I I I don't think I've ever
told somebody to go borrow money except
for I'm telling you right now because
you have a court order in your hand you
have to have this money by this date
period or you are in violation of a
court order right and so
um and because Dave and I've talked
about it but I
please don't borrow another penny for
anything else the attorneys can wait
you'll they'll put them on a payment
plan they'll get you'll get them paid
off when it's time
um these you can't afford bro you cannot
afford to fix this house up right now
because you're broke because you owe
your wife your ex-wife fifty thousand
dollars just it's just not the minute
man I know you want to wipe the Slate
clean you've probably been dealing with
this divorce for a long time hurting
relationships for a long time you want
to just wipe this slate clean you can't
do that right now and what's hard is
there's like something mentally about
well it's 50 000 what's another 20 right
I mean like there's like this like
mental Snowball Effect that happens Mark
when you go down this train or down this
track and that's what John's saying is
there has to be a blocker to at some
point saying I'm doing this because
there's like literally a court order out
uh what for the house Mark what makes
you so attached to this house I'm just
curious how much it's how much you owe
on it and what could you sell it for
uh I currently owe like two 242 000 on
the house okay I bought it I bought it
for 260.
um it's currently it appraised for 390.
um but there are comps in the area that
went for like 424. okay
yeah I mean
the how the house isn't really a major
issue at this point just because you
have your income's great I mean you
bring home 96 000. so if you honestly
buckle down you could pay this off in 12
to 18 months and be done with it and
then start saying okay what's with the
lawyers putting them on a payment plan
throughout this
um and get all this kind of cleaned up
and then the the house repairs and stuff
I would just I would put on hold for 12
months because and John speaks to this a
lot but when there's a lot of life
change like this I mean you literally
just came out of that mediation
yesterday of figuring out the finances
so this is all still even though it's
probably been a process I mean this
stuff is still very new Mark and these
emotional times it can cause
it can cause us to not make great
financial decisions and that's what I
don't want you to do Mark I want you to
be as minimal as possible when you're
making these decisions most people
experience when they get through the
divorce and that final that everybody
shakes hands
as you're getting out of the ring and
what you don't realize is that you get
out of the boxing ring after a long
fight and then Mike Tyson's waiting for
you in the parking lot because you're
going to be in month 10 paying this
fifty thousand dollars off
and you're going to be so enraged that
you are still dealing with this divorce
and the quicker you make peace with that
and know that this is all paying into
this new life that you're building
because that season's over dude
otherwise you're going to lose sleep
you're just gonna be angry all the time
and man I would if I'm you honestly I
would I would consider because I've got
so many memories in that house selling
the house I consider taking out a HELOC
as quickly as possible or personal loan
and I would put the house on the market
tomorrow and just sell the house take
all a couple hundred thousand dollars in
equity and kind of control delete
because you're you're going to be
building a new life now
and I would take that into consideration
but I'm also kind of a clean the Slate
kind of guy not everybody's like that so
um I'm just telling you what I would do
in my situation you don't have to do
that but yeah please in fact if you want
to just the letter of the law I would
take out a personal loan for 48 000 and
you've got four in the bank
um or 47 000 and you got four in the
bank and I would use three you already
have just for principles yes yes just so
it's like this personal conviction point
of saying I'm following through with
this to the to the nth degree that I can
but I have the ability to I refuse to
chain myself to a financial institution
because of her that's what I would tell
myself over and I refuse to lock myself
in a cage in a bigger loan that I need
in a bigger loan than I need because of
her I'm not doing it I'm not doing her
because of the lawyers I'm not doing it
yeah I refuse to lock myself in a cage
for that yeah but for new cabinets for
God's sake right right and that's that's
where the stuff can spiral out of
control really fast Mark and again it's
it is that emotional side of money that
it would feel good to like have some
newness in this place that has so many
memories and to redo the thing that
you've always wanted you guys fought
like like I get it I get that feeling of
like wanting to do something and make
progress on something even if it's
cabinets but it's like oh I just want to
get I just want to you know finish this
and do this and redo that
um but yeah I mean I think John brings
up an interesting point mark I think
yeah like you said John everyone's not
like you of the complete slate the Clean
Slate but I mean I would consider if
you're I don't know what your family
situation is we're about to head into a
break but
um but there is something about buying
something new and not even having to
downsize like just significantly yeah
and just being and then kind of letting
life cool off get the money in order
getting the money under control not
owing all of this taking some of that
Equity paying some of this and you're
really just starting from Ground Zero at
that point and building on top of that
instead of just kind of like being in
this hole but that's just that's the
point I mean I think you're okay to keep
the home if you want to but
um I think it's something just just to
consider as another as another option
Mark sorry what you're going through and
I appreciate you calling us and
hopefully hopefully that helped oh
that's been an hour in the books thanks
to everyone in the booth for helping us
out this hour thank you John for
co-hosting and thank you America for
listening this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am Ramsay
personality Rachel Cruz co-hosting today
with my friend Anne Ramsay personality
Dr John deloney and we are answering
your calls and it's a free call anywhere
in the country at triple eight eight two
five five two two five all right first
up this hour we have Chuck in Madison
Wisconsin hey Chuck welcome to the show
no you're supposed to say what's up
Chuck that's my good throw up joke for
the day what's up man sorry
that's all right hey thanks for getting
me on my wife and I are big time
listeners to the show
um but we're going through a little bit
of a we're not on the same page but it's
something we wanted to get your take on
perfect we're the perfect people to ask
Rachel and I agree on everything Chuck
so we got you cool okay so um anyway my
wife Jamie and I started the um we do
went through Financial Peace University
started at the end of last November
and we've been working the steps we
finished
uh step two the middle of last month
congratulations step free yeah yeah we
paid off about forty thousand dollars
awesome yeah and so we're working step
three we're building our emergency fund
um you know we got you know we're
getting there
but anyway the Dilemma is my wife and I
have different views on on what to do
next after we build the emergency fund
she would like to
um we start looking for houses sell our
house
um and downsize you know buy something
that we can afford obviously
and have a lesser mortgage but have a
mortgage and my thought is
I really I really dig the idea of being
like just hammering away at the house we
live in and and having it paid off I'm
not sure how long that would take maybe
two three years
um and then having all that money
afterwards to go buy whatever else we
want you know and I don't know I'm not
my wife's super smart she's super
efficient you know I love her and I'm
not trying to win because I know at the
end of the day I probably wouldn't win
I'd think I won but I didn't win
okay I just want to hear from you guys
what you think yeah okay tell me your
current house
um how much you guys owe on it
uh we owe 148 000 on the house 148 how
much is it worth
it's worth about 350 360. it could be
worth more I'm not sure yeah and how
much uh do you guys make a year
132 000. 132. okay
and her big reason to sell the house is
what's her number one reason she just
wants to get out of debt that much
faster she doesn't like the house why
does she want to move no she loves the
house it's bigger than she likes uh she
would like less cleaning I mean we both
clean but she does you know more
um just because I'm out out in the field
a lot working yeah not in the field but
you know out and about and
um
and yeah she she said we'd have less
we'd have less to pay off
if we you know because we're gonna we'd
make some money off the house we'd have
less we'd have less of a mortgage we'd
have a mortgage with less of a mortgage
she's right on that so like
your idea of I want to be debt free and
not owe anybody anything is Noble that's
awesome and she's trying to tell you hey
wait I could expedite that and so it
doesn't sound like the money's the issue
it sounds like you love your house
I do
it's a great house I mean and the truth
is I we moved from this house we lived
in a house I I had two daughters I
raised on my own
for a long time you know we had about
900 square feet
and
and we moved to a house that's really
nice and big
so it is excuse me it's a little
emotional for me yeah is this this house
is the signal to the world that you made
it you bounce back is that right right
right right right right and you have
your wife who you love telling you hey
honey
we made it
yeah let's go together yeah yeah that's
it I mean that's it and and I know we'd
land on her feet wherever we were
wherever we end up I know we'd be okay
um together
um but it's hard for me okay so that's
really the big question is what why this
house plays such a role for you I mean
it does for for many reasons
right yeah right so how much of like
Chuck's identity would just die a little
bit if you guys moved to a smaller home
like what does that just do to you
um
good question uh
yeah I mean I I just think it
I I think it would just be a little ego
deflating yeah so let me let me tell you
something I called a sign like we're
okay we're actually gonna be debt free
completely let me tell you something
happened to me this is embarrassing and
it's the first time I've ever told us
publicly okay yeah so I have been
chasing for my whole life
my sister was one of the most brilliant
people you can possibly imagine my
little brother missed like two questions
on the act or something and then I was
the dumb football jock okay I was the
dumb kid in the middle and I have been
chasing with all of my heart
I I want to show you that I'm smart I'm
smart too I'm smart too and I kept going
to school I kept taking out loans I kept
getting all these certificates and
achievements spent time at Harvard I
went everywhere trying to get all these
external indicators that I was smart
and then
I took a job at Ramsey and I'll never
forget my onboarding day with the head
of hr's name is Armando he's awesome and
I said hey where do I send all my
transcripts and my degrees
and he looked at me and said
I'm not here I don't need them
and I said no no but like what do you
like where do I send my my certificates
because they're in really fancy frames
and he was like Hey we've already hired
you man like uh we hire people who can
do the job well and Hey listen I was I
didn't know what to do
I I was stunned at how much my identity
was wrapped up in being able to prove to
people that I had this class one time
right I want to tell you this it took
some time unwinding it I can't tell you
how free I am of all of it my wife loves
me and my kids are healthy and they love
me and that's about what I need wow I
want to tell you if you will do that
work of walking through that house room
by room and praying over it and saying
this is where this memory was and we
made it and then go to the next room if
you can untethered yourself from that
however many years you have left on this
Earth You will run free Freer than you
can possibly imagine because now I don't
care now I don't care man I just don't
care yeah does that make sense yeah Amen
brother yeah sure and Chuck I don't want
to throw this like wrench into the
beautiful thing that John just said but
let me just I just want to say as we get
off the phone here that like you guys
aren't in a director you don't have to
sell it right so if you guys keep it you
can yeah you can pay it off your wife's
like hey we I don't really want this big
of a house all this so it's more of your
reasons of why and if your reason of why
is staying because it's just unhealthy
and Chuck wants to feel like oh my gosh
I've made it that's not a reason to stay
and if she's exhausted from cleaning it
it's too big she's like we can downsize
and be so happy it'd be a challenge for
you but I think it's more of an
emotional play than a money play either
way you guys are fine no great you're
fine stay in the house financially
you're fine move Financial you're fine
you're fine
but it's more of a question of why why
are we staying and the why is not
sounding like the hell unhook yourself
in those extrinsic markers man they
don't matter thanks for calling Chuck
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney and taking your calls if
you'll do us a favor you guys and share
the show that would really be very
helpful because so many of you are new
on YouTube or podcast and getting to
spread the word of the show is so
helpful not only to get the show in
front of more people but ultimately with
that leads to hopefully is you know the
idea that people are now gaining control
of their life whether it's their money
their relationships their job we just
want to spread hope and the more people
that listen hopefully the more hope that
is spread and the best way you can do
that is by subscribing leaving a review
and again forwarding maybe some of these
episodes on to your friends and family
would help us so much all right up next
we have Jordan in Greenville hey Jordan
welcome to the show
Hi how are you we're doing well thanks
for calling how can we help
all right so I'm married I'm 23 my wife
is 21 and we have a six month old son oh
congratulations
oh thank you my wife is a stay-at-home
mom and so I work full-time and take
care of both of them
and it sticks between 55 and 65 000 a
year because I'm a mechanic so it's a
flat rate pay
and we have two car loans so I have an
eleven thousand dollar car loan and a
nine thousand dollar car loan
and we're in beta step one right now but
I'm getting a big paycheck at the end of
the month so we should have that done by
then great
um I want to see basically what's the
best way to
payoff is there and should I sell the
cars and get one car that's they can pay
cash for
um because we only really need one car
since my mom my wife is a stay-at-home
mom yeah yeah
um well Jordan you know one of our
big goals is to get you out of debt as
fast as possible because your income is
going to be your largest wealth building
tool your income is going to be the
thing that's going to help make you more
money down the line to be able to you
know do anything with your life that you
want hopefully and be generous and all
that so freeing up these car payments is
going to be one of the The Next Step
that we're really going to focus on like
you mentioned for baby step two so
um I mean they're not the the numbers
are not completely out of whack but I
will tell you
um you know talking to Jade warshaw one
of our other Ramsay personalities her
and her husband Sam went down to one car
for a season and they were like we just
want to get out of debt as fast as
possible and for some people that's hey
I'm going to take on an extra job I
don't know how much you can cut
lifestyle wise Jordan you may not have a
ton um you guys may be just living right
you know where you are but if there's
anything to cut and get extra money to
throw at this debt uh but I think upping
your income would be the probably the
best step and that may be working nights
that may be working weekends or
or
yeah do you sell do you sell these cars
get one car for a while that's not
awesome but it runs and then you guys
save on the side up for a car because
you don't have these car payments like
how many what's the car payment on the
11 000 car a month
um 311 a month okay
236. okay smaller one yeah so I mean
like uh
yeah I mean I mean you're yeah you're
looking at call 8550 freed up a month in
car lines of what you could save to
continue to replace it right because I
think about cars because you know you
can you can sell a car
you can put some savings on top step up
and car save on the side keep stepping
up you can work your way back up to cars
so I'm wondering have you Kelly Blue
booked these by chance I'm just curious
what they're worth
so the eleven thousand dollar car is the
older Toyota 2009 and it's worth each of
the cars are worth about a thousand
dollars less than what we owe is what I
figured okay
um
so either way we'd be not incredibly
upside down but sort of
yeah so as a flat rate mechanic are you
allowed to go work at another shop on
Saturdays and Sundays are you allowed to
do work at your house
so right now I work six days a week so I
worked about 60 hours a week by choice
um most of us work about 50 but I've
been working Monday through Saturday and
I'm looking into
maybe picking up a an extra shift for
like a retail store or
um we're just putting some headphones in
and driving Uber here's what everybody I
know that has done this successfully
has sat down with their spouse and had a
season of sacrifice and what that would
mean for you is you're going to miss
some big moments and there are little
moments but you're going to miss some
playing in the backyard time and you had
this picture I'm gonna be this kind of
dad and what I would tell you is the
greatest gift you can give your kid is
your presence and there's a caveat to
that it's a non-anxious presence if you
are home and stressed about money and
you and your wife are anxious and you're
sitting apart from each other on the
couch that's not the kind of presence
that's great for your kid
and so it's better to sacrifice if you
and your wife sat down and you all
mapped it out and you said hey if I take
a retail job I deliver pizzas I drive
for Uber whatever on the way to work on
the way home from work I pick up another
shift
um I work overtime whatever it is and I
do that for nine months and we're done
we owe nobody anything and we've got
part of our emergency fund completely
packed up
I'm telling you right now being a dad on
the other side of that that nine month
commitment would be worth it and you'd
hate every second of it and it would
stamp into your soul I will never borrow
money again
yeah absolutely yeah does that make
sense
yeah that makes sense and that's my big
thing is like
I just I hate the burden of knowing that
we can only save
not a time I mean occasionally I get a
good bonus that lets me save a little
bit
um
it was only just recently gotten to this
point where we're really serious about
budgeting and we have the every dollar
app good so especially being on only my
income the idea that I can get us debt
free so that we have more margin to
where we can have some peace in our
house yeah it would be amazing yeah so
Jordan I mean looking at your numbers
I'm like okay you're going to be two
grand upside down right a grand a piece
per car so if you guys took out you know
um
an eight thousand dollar loan two grand
for the difference that gives you six
grand to go buy a car and be a one-car
family for a season uh I mean that's
eight thousand versus twenty thousand
right so that gets you out of debt
faster I'd rather be working towards
eight grand than 20 grand and keep these
cars the cars are not crazy though it's
not one of these that like oh gosh you
absolutely have to sell them uh your
numbers are not that extreme but again
we find the people that go the most
extreme which that would be it selling
both cars getting a beat one beater
going down to a one car family get you
out of that debt and up on level grounds
faster and then you guys be you know
you're saving up for probably half of an
emergency fund half of another car if
you if you know if your wife's like all
right it's been four months I need a car
you're saving up for yeah you're saving
up for a second car and your emergency
fund and you just kind of keep trucking
along that way right I mean that's
that's it so it's basically how fast you
guys want to get out and the fastest way
would be to sell the cars and take out a
small loan to get a to get a beater and
that and that's what you're working or
you choose to buckle down and say hey
we're gonna pay these off it's gonna be
20 Grands of cardet how long is that
going to take us so I would map it out I
would sit down Jordan with your wife and
you guys did you say she's like you guys
have a six month old right
yeah yeah so I would map out exactly a
very detailed timeline honestly it helps
me when I see information in front of me
and I would say okay let's say we went
with plan a and we sold the cars all of
that we'll have eight grand we have to
save up we have we have to get out of
debt for how many hours am I gonna have
to work how many days is that how many
Saturdays like map it out Jordan all the
way and say all right and then if we
want to buy a five thousand dollar car
for you how long is that going to take
to save up all that like map out that
situation A and then map out situation B
we keep both cars but we're going to
work hard and pay them off
and pay off this 20 grand how long how
often do I have to work how many hours
how many days and you guys pick your
scenario right you're not I don't think
either one's right or wrong but the only
thing you have to do in that
conversation is be honest yes I can't I
can't breathe with owing this money yep
is I don't feel safe being yes in this
house at a single income house and owing
27 000 on these cars I you've got to be
honest and that's hard for folks to do
sometime at that meeting yeah when your
wife says well I don't want you gone
that much okay you've said what you want
and I hear that and I need I need to be
honest with you I can't sleep I can't
sleep yep and I'm pacing the house while
you're asleep and you don't even know it
because I can't believe I've put us in
this position right so everybody's got
to be honest and for everybody listening
When Rachel said go down to one car and
you thought oh but that would screw up
nap time for yes we know
we know it'll mess up everything and it
will free you forever yes that's right
absolutely this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour Dr John
deloney and we are taking your calls up
next we have Jody in Milwaukee hey Jody
welcome to the show
Hi how are you hi we're doing great
thanks for giving us a call how can we
help
hi so um I currently own a condo with my
mother oh no oh no
I don't even know what you're about to
say but oh no
yes so uh I want to get it in my name
within the next year
um and my grandfather is
um wants to give me 15 000 but my mom
said I have to send 100 of the 15 000
renovating the condo which I don't think
it should be spent that much because uh
I purchased a condo we purchase condo
under market value but only eight
thousand dollars under market value so I
feel like to spend fifteen thousand
dollars in renovations I don't even know
if it would resell for that much
yeah how much did you spend on the condo
[Music]
and you're with your and you that you
took out a mortgage is it just your name
on the mortgage
no it's both of our names both names
whose names are on the deed
uh my mother's
your mom's okay yeah so I'm telling you
this Jody Rachel you tell me if I'm
wrong but I'm telling you this Jody for
the sake of your soul and if you happen
to have kids their soul and your
relationship with your mom long term
I would do what I could to sell
my part of that or to get out of the
deal or to walk away
because it's going to collapse your it's
going to collapse your relationship with
your mom and a one bedroom condo for
seventy two thousand dollars is is not
worth that there's no condo worth your
relationship with your mom
but this is just gonna be the beginning
of it
yes do you feel that Jody or do you feel
or would you say no John everything's
great like we have a great relationship
it's fine
yeah um it's been a little difficult
um but she's telling me where to spend
my money or what needs to be renovated
and I pay a hundred percent of the
mortgage yeah
no no no no no then we're selling 100 of
that of the condo if you're paying for
it what is she contributing to it
um well basically I didn't have much of
a credit score so she uh kind of put in
her name for me so I have like a a year
and a half to get in my name but I paid
100 of the mortgage in the HOA fees but
she lives there
yeah I live here she doesn't live here
oh she's not living with you no oh okay
so you live in the condo yes okay so you
need to refinance and get her name off
the mortgage correct yes okay the issue
is I want to refinance and use the money
my grandfather wants to give me but she
uh yes she doesn't get it she doesn't
get a vote yeah that's the complication
she just became his uh POA like just a
couple weeks ago then listen if your mom
is going to steal the money that your
granddad earmarked for you
yeah then walk away from that
relationship she is opting out a
relationship with her daughter if she
steals the money that was earmarked for
for you she doesn't get a vote in that
money her your granddad did not leave
you money you money for her to tell you
but running all your purchase Decisions
by your mom he said I love my
granddaughter I trust her she's been
really special and I'm gonna bless her
with fifteen thousand dollars and you
want to spend fifteen thousand dollars
to take your mortgage which is smart
thank you so no I I if your mom steals
your money I would walk away from my mom
and I listen I am not saying that
lightly I understand how devastating
that is to say out loud into here
why does she care so much Jody why I
mean I don't understand it's not like
you're saying I'm gonna go to Europe for
fifteen thousand dollars and have the
time of my life what's her what's her
reasoning do you know I have no idea she
comes to my house and tells me what what
needs to be replaced and he first said
she's going to refinance in both of our
names so I don't know if she's going to
try to do a Cash out refinance I don't
know her plans but she just kept saying
well let's just uh refinance and vote
for our names for now until you can get
in here no no no no no do that no no
yeah I think Jody I think there's going
to be up to a really blunt kind
hard conversation with her and you're
gonna and John's the perfect one to be
sitting next to me to tell you how to
walk through that conversation but you
need to have some very clear boundaries
with your mom and I think you can be
very kind about it Jody but I think you
need to say Ma how old are you Jody
I'm 27. okay Joe to you're 27. mom I'm
27 years old I is this is this too
passive aggressive John but I would be
like you're a total vocal tone is yes
we're not passive aggressive is this too
kind because if I'm Jody and my mom is
doing this because her mom I would think
your mom's not a malicious person she
probably is thinking I'm helping her
she's played this role in your life for
27 years and I think the conversation is
Mom I I appreciate you wanting to help
me and I appreciate your input and what
you say and you know what Mom you're
probably right you're saying I need to
replace my microwave I probably do thank
you but Mom I'm 27 years old
and I'm gonna start to stand on my own
two feet which means I don't want input
for you right now there may be a time
and a place in life that I open that
door back up because I do appreciate you
and who you are
but right now I'm making my own
decisions about everything and so when
you come over
I'm not going to allow you in my
apartment my condo to tell me what to do
this is my condo and I want you to
respect that and when I go to your house
Mom I don't want to tell you what to do
I don't want that relationship so that's
the boundary I have to set mom in
another part of that boundary is this
money the Granddad has left me and I'm
going to use the money that he left me
to refinance into this name so that
you're off the mortgage and we can have
a more clean relationship because I'm
scared that this is going to be a
Fallout mom I want to do this to protect
our relationship right yeah is that too
kind or is that no because I want to
respect your mom I think the key here is
everything is about you not not her
I want you to be my mom not my business
partner and I'm struggling with how
you're my business partner because we
both signed this deal and you want your
business to look like this and I want it
to look like this and I am feeling uh my
relationship with my mom is getting in
trouble and it's not worth any of this
and so I'm going to take that money and
I want to move this house into my name
and your mom that's her job is to come
over and say well you should fix the car
that's fine but I'm not doing any of
that stuff if I can't afford it and if I
don't want to because it's my house and
so I would I when you start lobbing
grenades because you're doing this and
you keep telling me this then she is has
to go on the defensive right she's got
to defend herself and then this thing
gets into a mess and so I would just sit
down there and say I I I need my mom
back and I don't want to be business
partners with you so yeah no you're
right Rachel you're right your approach
is the right way
um but honestly you said she's not
malicious this is bordering on malicious
this is boarding on a mom who can't let
go in my right
yes I'm her only child so she has um
yeah so
um there may be some magic
and you taking her out for coffee or for
breakfast and putting your arms across
the table and holding your hands and
saying you did a good job
um
you did a good job and you raised me a
strong powerful young woman but I need
to start making some of these decisions
on my own and learn how to do this or I
I can't keep going to the gym and you
keep lifting the weights for me I've got
to start lifting weights on my own
and
sometimes letting a parent know because
they there there's a lot of anxious
energy they're trying to help and help
and help improve and probably yeah yeah
and it's like hey whoa you did your job
you did so good now I just need my mom
I don't need a business partner I don't
need a complaint partner I don't need a
buddy I need my mom and um that may not
work but the next step is I put in the
house on the market and I'm moving or
the next step is
um if you steal money from me that my
granddad left me then we're gonna have
some other issues do you see what I'm
saying so Rachel's ideas is perfect
okay how do you think she'd respond to
that Jody not well
[Applause]
try to have conversations with her
before so we'll see oh shoot I want you
to think of it this way
if you hold your boundary after you are
clear about it and she violates that
boundary mom I do not want to talk about
X I don't want to talk about why I'm not
going to do this and she chooses to
force that on you she is the one opting
out of relationship with you not the
other way around the boundaries aren't
what's going to divide you it's going to
be her choice to either violate or to
uphold those boundaries that you put out
there and she's an adult she gets to
make those choices yep uh Jody thanks
for calling I hope that helps this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
second Corinthians 9 8 and God is able
to bless you abundantly so that in all
things at all times having all that you
need you will abound in every good work
and today's quote of the day is by the
great and wonderful Maya Angelou she
writes nothing will work
unless you do
golly she's the best
so good ah man uh all right well we're
gonna go to the phones next up we have
Mary in Minneapolis hey Mary welcome to
the show
hi thank you yes absolutely how can we
help
um I guess I'm just wondering I'm buying
a home unless it's a better idea to
if I wanted to rent
um and then I can go more into detail
about my situation yeah what's the deal
okay
uh uh so I'm getting a divorce
um sorry and I'm it you know I think
that's so funny people say that it I
mean it's it's okay it really is
um it's mutual it's fine
it is what it is you know but
um I'm just trying to figure out what's
my situation going on like if it's
better idea to run first
or if I if you think it could be doable
to buy a home
okay like right at the beginning of
maybe 2024 it doesn't have to be like
immediate but yeah I don't I don't know
your financial situation but I would
recommend six six months to a year of no
major life decisions after this and you
can say it's mutual all you want I know
how what a mess that process is even
when it's amicable it's a mess and the
death of that picture I had like
unwinding that it just takes time and so
I I don't know you can work with Rachel
through the numbers but I would not buy
anything for a season yeah where are you
currently living Mary
uh Chicago okay I mean like in a home
are you moving like what's your current
living situation oh I'm living with a
parent at the moment okay and will you
be staying in the Chicago area then
yeah just so I cannot save up enough
money to hopefully afford a home by next
year but if you think I don't know yeah
okay so
um do you have any money saved
I have about 1500 in savings okay um
yeah I I don't know I do have a Roth IRA
obviously I'm not going to use it right
now sure okay what kind of debt do you
have
um I did buy a vehicle uh
and it's funny that he says that you
shouldn't make any like major life
decisions because I I made one kind of
on a whim because that's why I tell
people don't do that yeah I know well
like okay so we we used a vehicle
together before we were married so it
was under both our names for two almost
three years
and um I had
he was a little pushy on making sure his
name was off of it before we got
divorced and so
yeah no I made I try my best to make it
happen just I needed a vehicle in order
to get to and from work and that leased
vehicle I wouldn't have been able to
afford it yeah
um so you took out a loan for how much
uh about twenty thousand twenty thousand
okay what other debts you have
uh that is it actually that is like the
only day yeah okay and how much money do
you make a year
about fifty thousand fifty thousand okay
um
so on a whim I'm curious I know you
didn't call about the car but I would be
curious if you Kelly Blue booked it what
it would be
um I literally I bought it about a month
and a half ago now
um so I'm in the contract you know
whatever but uh yeah no I Kelley Blue
booked it it's worth about 22.
okay
yeah I would so so I know you called
about the house and here's the deal um
if I was in your situation right now I
would not buy a home I would rent
somewhere not only because of the life
change you're going through but also
financially because I want you to have a
fully funded emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses saved in the bank
and then saving up for a down payment
and that's all after your debt free so
you can really expedite that whole
process if you sell this car right if
you if you get out of this car loan and
you you know you're gonna make two grand
on it and you know save up a little bit
and get not a great car but you know six
thousand dollar car or something to get
you to and from work and what you need
um that's going to lower your debt
amount significantly to be able to get
out of that pay that off save up a big
chunk of money for an emergency fund and
then save for a down payment so you're
still a little ways off not crazy not
you know it's not
too far-fetched but right now yeah in
your situation Mary I would rent I think
that's a great option just because home
ownership is so expensive I mean anytime
anything happens it's up to you and it
it always seems to be when you buy a
house
you know eight months later the heating
and air goes out and then the water
heater you know it's just there's a lot
of big expenses and when you have debt
and no savings it creates a burden and a
stress point that could have been
avoided so if I were you I would be yeah
renting and saving up for paying off
this I would be paying off this debt I
would be saving up for an emergency fund
and then a down payment of at least five
percent is what I would put down in Mary
did I hear you say you're in the Chicago
area
yeah as of right now all right so
September 15th through 16th me Rachel
Dave Ramsey several of us are going to
be in Chicago doing a smart conference
it's an all-day event it's a Friday
night into Saturday and we're gonna run
through all of it relationship stuff
mental health work stuff in September
it's coming up money money three weeks
I'm gonna hook you up with two tickets
you and a guests are going to be my
guest and you can attend on us is that
cool
oh God that's awesome yeah that would be
sweet all right so hang on the line and
AJ Austin will get you hooked up there
and uh we'd love to see you there yeah
for sure yeah that conference will be a
good kind of jump start to to this new
chapter of your life Mary you know of
starting out because
um big changes like that are
it's hard it's difficult yeah and you
just want to start doing so much so fast
and you find yourself in a in your
parents basement with a car note and a I
don't know yeah
absolutely all right let's go to George
in Washington DC hey George welcome to
the show
thank you very much how are you guys we
are doing well how can we help
great good deal so real quickly I know
you'll have a couple minutes
um a number of years ago our family
friend I'm actually her uncle and she
refers me as her aunt her uncle and I
call her my God knees I had told her
sort of half cash I have seriously that
I would help her you know or I would
actually give her a car when she got out
of high school but back then her takes
were like in the beater cars and like
less expensive cars and I didn't think
there'd ever amount to this but she got
out of high school ended up getting
married life goes on you know she's now
asked about a car my wife and I two and
a half years ago when we got married it
you know offered her a 15 year old Lexus
it was a cream puff with 100K miles on
it
um we would take care of all the repairs
if there were any that were needed and
she was livid and annoyed about it uh
you know kind of in my mind a spoiled
brat it's in my mind too everyone's mind
in America so good god oh my god well
yeah maybe not hers though but anyway
well she doesn't get a vote so my
question is and I I got a call with her
mom and her and I said well you know I
would help but I'm not going to be
buying you a two-year-old car with 5 000
miles on it for twenty thousand dollars
that's nuts so you know what how do I
approach this what you know what do I
say to her what do I ask her I would
begin or am I completely off the hook if
she turned it because she turned down
this other car I mean yeah I mean in a
sense you guys offered her a car but
also George I would you know sit down
with your wife figure out hey we have
this amount to put help her towards a
car if she wants to use it towards a car
or this amount to to buy a car it's
whatever you guys can financially do
that is wise and you feel good about so
if that's
Seven Grand that's great you go find a
seven Grand car and say hi sweet grand
niece that's not even my real niece uh
we talked about a car this is where
we're at financially if you would like
this gift we would love to bless you
with this gift if you're gonna give me
the middle finger and hate it then then
God bless and fly and be free it's a
great Jay-Z says brush your shoulders
off man yeah just walk on Georgia a very
honorable man and I think if you if you
feel like you want to stick to your word
you guys figure out together you and
your wife what what is the best amount
but I mean how she however she responds
is how she responds and by the way
there's a huge difference you don't have
to even do this on a high school kid
like hey I got you and then after high
school she's like no I'm good and then
after college and then she comes back 20
years later and she's like hey remember
that time I know and by the way I want
it to be red and good God any anybody
turns down Alexis oh my gosh George I
don't have words I don't have the words
thanks for calling thank you America
thanks to everyone in the booth John
great show today thanks for listening
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the Ramsay way
just go to ramseysolutions.com today to
sign up for our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]